president trump's former u.n ambassador
nikki haley joins us now from washington
good morning ambassador
what did the republican party uh what
does the republican party need to do
this week do you think
and did they start it last night good
morning well i think they absolutely
started it last night i mean talking
about
how the country is a work in progress
and we have to continue to build on that
progress you know whether it is trying
to
overcome covet whether it's trying to
fight off china and iran whether it's
trying to continue to
build our economy back up to where
president trump had it
before covet hit you know all of those
things
education choices and going further i
mean those are all things that we need
to continue to do and i think the
republican party needs to
continue to talk about policies and
substance and where we're going from
here
uh as ben tracy uh reported uh the the
republican party
said going in that this was going to be
an optimistic command convention
but a lot of people saw a very dark
picture painted last night about the
democrats that there were going to be
vengeful mobs storming the suburbs
that doesn't sound very optimistic well
i think it's because they turn on the tv
and that's what they see they look at
the protest they look at the riots they
look at the rage
and they see what's happening in
portland they see what's happening in
wisconsin they see those things and
you know i can tell you from south
carolina
we had we know what it's like to have a
dirty cop we
we dealt with one when one shot walter
scott in the back
multiple times when he was unarmed but
we came together
we talked about it we passed the first
body camera bill in the country
we didn't have the riots in the rage and
that's what this is all about
lawlessness will not make progress
lawlessness does nothing but create more
lawlessness
and so that's where the republican party
is trying to take it is
look there is a better way and we have
to go towards that way as opposed to
just going towards violence and rage
but we have we have yet another shooting
as you said in wisconsin
you sing you're seeing overnight
reactions to that
if you're a black person in this country
shouldn't you by asking
why does it why does this keep happening
absolutely we should ask questions but
that's just it we've got to find out
exactly what happened in this domestic
dispute
what the background is but it never it
it's always a good thing to talk
about what is happening what the fears
are what the concerns are and how we're
going to take us to the next level you
know i can tell you in south carolina
one of the things that we found is you
can't move a dirty cop from one area to
another area because the dirty cop is
going to do the same thing
you have to have the reason we passed
body cameras is you have to have
accountability
for good cops and for bad cops but the
one thing you don't do is you don't
demonize all police officers in the
process
we've got a lot of good police officers
we created
that body camera bill we did it with law
enforcement we did it with walter
scott's family
we did it by talking about what we
needed to do to improve not by
demonizing the good guys you go by
holding the bad guys accountable
that's what needs to be happening
ambassador uh the president continues to
downplay the coronavirus saying again
yesterday the virus is going to go away
the death toll is now at 170 77 000. we
had 38 000 new cases yesterday
do you consider the administration's
response to the virus successful
well listen there's not an american in
this country that shouldn't be furious
at china
for covering up lying and allowing this
to get to this point
having said that these are unprecedented
times there is no president
that could have predicted this was going
to happen but the key
is how do we make today better than
yesterday our testing is better
the fact that one of the things that
will go down is one of the best things
the president has done is
loosening up the regulations so that
pharmaceutical companies can actually
help us get a vaccine that's going to be
huge
we're going to have that by december
we're going to hopefully have everybody
treated and next spring that will be a
new day
but we are now trying to push through
that are the lives that we've lost okay
no but that's why we're all so angry at
china that's why we want them held
accountable
that's why we called out the world
health organization we have to keep
doing those things so that
should there god forbid ever be another
virus
that this does not happen again nikki
haley thank you very much for being with
us this morning
thanks so much